[Musik]
zu Beginn des Jahres 2022 war nur von
einer Sache die Rede die Russen kommen
der Aufmarsch an der ukrainischen Grenze
schien deutlich zu machen dass die
Invasion nur eine Frage der Zeit sein
würde und fast alle rechnenden damals
mit einem Triumphzug Putins erinnerst du
dich noch
Februar 2022 us-waffenlieferung an die
Ukraine würden eine russische Invasion
zwar abschwächen aber nicht aufhalten
die russische Armee könnte das
ukrainische Militär schnell überwältigen
selbst wenn es von den Vereinigten
Staaten und ihren europäischen
Verbündeten unterstützt wird 5 Januar
2022 die ukrainische Armee ist
unterfinanziert unterlegen und nicht
darauf vorbereitet eine russische
Invasion aufzuhalten die sind nur zwei
Beispiel für das was allgemeiner Konsens
zu sein schienen ohne ein großes Wunder
hätten die ukrainische Streitkräfte
keine Chance gegen Russland gigantische
und mächtige Kriegsmaschine Ring zu
dieser Zeit war die Rede davon sehr
Lenski zu erwerben oder einen Krieg so
starken doch die Ukraine hielten durch
und das trotz aller Widrigkeiten
[Musik]
seit Monaten sehen die Ukraine wie ihre
Städte Dörfer und Felder dem Erdboden
gleichgemacht werden die Zahl der
Todesopfer geht in die Zehntausende die
Russen haben Kraftwerke tausende von
Schulen hunderte von Krankenhäusern und
alle Arten von Infrastruktur zerstört um
die eine Vorstellung zu geben im April
2023 überstieg der geschätzte direkte
Schaden der durch den Krieg verursacht
wurde bereits 150 Milliarden Dollar die
Ukraine mussten sich Bomben Kälte und
Dunkelheit stellen und doch haben sie
durchgehalten und nicht nur das jetzt
haben sie sogar die Initiative zurück
gewonnen sagen wir einfach dass die
Ukraine diesen Krieg unter keinen
Umständen verlieren wollten mehr noch
jetzt wollen sie unbedingt gewinnen die
Frage die große Frage die wir immer noch
nicht beantwortet haben ist aber warum
eigentlich nach all dem Leid und den
Entbehrungen ist der Kampfgeist der
Ukraine nach wie vor ungebrochen wieso
hat es Wladimir Putin trotzdem
maskenhaften bombardi nicht geschafft
ihre Volkszähler und ihren Widerstand zu
brechen genau diese entscheidende Frage
werden wir uns heute hier auf der so
alle Politik stellen und da in der
deutschen und österreichischen Presse in
letzter Zeit immer wieder zu lesen war
die ukrainische Gegenoffensive sei
gescheitert werden am Ende dieses Videos
auch zu diesem Thema eine genaue Analyse
abgeben du wirst sehen auch wenn
Experten fescheuniformen tragen und
ultra seriös in die Kamera blicken
müssen Sie nicht unbedingt richtig
liegen was ich ja übrigens auch schon in
der Vergangenheit öfter gezeigt hat aber
es geht mir ja gar nicht darum so gemein
zu sein ein Hawaiihemd kann ja auch eine
Art Uniform darstellen und das hier ist
doch ein halber Hemd oder seht ihr die
Fahne hier gut auf jeden Fall würde mich
nachher mal interessieren welche
Erfahrungen du mit dem analytischen und
prognistischen Tracker verschiedene
Experten und Analysten hast erzähl uns
davon doch mal unten im Kommentarbereich
und schreibt uns auch was wir eventuell
besser machen könnten lass uns vorher
aber noch einen kurzen werbe Hinweis
unseres Träumen spielt denn surfshark
hat auch ein VPN im Angebot das wirklich
empfehlenswert und vor allem sicher und
vertrauenswürdig ist so lockt es z.B
selbstverständlich keinerlei
Verbindungsdaten mit natürlich kann ein
Wäsche privat einen nicht vor allem
Gefahren man muss nach wie vor
unsichthalten lassen Unwissen was man
tut aber es stellt hierfür ein Werkzeug
mir gleich mehreren Vorteilen da zum
einen erschwert ist in Kombination mit
anderen Vorkehrungen eure Aktion im Netz
nachzuverfolgen und abzuhören mit Hilfe
verschiedener Sicherheitsfeatures könnt
ihr so eure Anonymität im Netz erhöhen
zum Beispiel mit dem integrierten
klimberg das alle unerwünschten Cookies
und Popups blockt weiterer Vorteil ist
dass ihr so tun könnt als wäre die an
einem anderen Ort so könnt ihr z.B auf
Webseite und Internet
verfügbar werden ob daheim oder im
Urlaub damit schlagt jetzt sind so und
hier blocking ein Schnäppchen Netflix
und anderes
anbieten von Europa oder deutsches
Internet gucken mit Surfer kein Problem
und das ist noch lange nicht alles damit
nur konnte wirklich alle eure Endgeräte
MVB registrieren Handys Notebooks oder
sogar euren Smart TV so und wenn ihr den
Rabattcode politik.de angeht bekommt ihr
von surfshark auch noch ein Rabatt in
Höhe von 83% und um deine ersten drei
Monate gratis dazu den Link zu diesem
Angebot findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter diesem Video also nichts hier los
besorgt damit auch gleichzeitig uns
finanzielle unter die Arme das könnt ihr
übrigens auch direkt mit Hilfe des
Spenden links ebenfalls in die besch
Reibung gepackt habe wir sind euch für
jede Unterstützung bei dem damit hätten
solche Zukunft noch mehr und noch
bessere Videos zu liefern so und du
lasst uns wieder schnell zur
Beantwortung unserer kritischen Frage
kommen warum ist der Kampfgeist der
Ukraine nach wie vor ungebrochen warum
wollen sie unbedingt bis zum Ende
durchhalten und ihr Land komplett von
den russischen Besatzern befreien
aufgepasst
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich denke wenn es etwas geht worüber wir
uns alle einig sind dann ist es der
überragende Erfolg des ukrainischen
Widerstands mit denen extrem wenige
gerechnet haben okay wir wissen jetzt
dass das russische militärunfähig ist
und russische waffenschrott ja wir
wissen auch dass die enorme Korruption
das russische Potenzial vollkommen
ausgesaugt hat und natürlich haben wir
alle die riesigen waffenströme gesehen
die von den westlichen Verbündeten in
die Ukraine geflossen sind aber trotzdem
ist es ein gigantischer Verdienst sich
gegen eine Armee aufzulegen die
zahlenmäßig waffentechnische räumlich
zunächst wohl auch logistisch Artillerie
technisch im Luftraum und den praktisch
jedem Bereich überlegen war halt in
jedem Bereich außerdem strategischen und
stellt euch vor dieser verrückt
klingende Widerstand hatte auch noch
Erfolg versetzen wir uns doch mal in
ihrer Lage es ist nicht gerade einfach
dem russischen Bären wenn er sich auf
dich stürzt in die Augen zu blicken und
dabei auch noch das Messer zwischen den
Zähnen zu behalten und doch ist es genau
das was die Ukraine geschafft haben kein
Wunder dass der Preis sehr hoch war und
er wird noch höher werden
in der Ukraine sind Zerstörung
Vernichtung und Todesopfer an der
Tagesordnung und zwar in einem Ausmaß
das man sich in Europa nicht mehr
vorstellen konnte erinnerst du dich an
die Bilder die die Sprengung des
novakarovkantons hinterlassen hat
hättest du dir eine solch gigantische
Katastrophe in Europa vorstellen können
oder die totale Vernichtung Mario Pols
oder dass die Russen gerade das größte
Kernkraftwerk Europas scharf vermieden
ich meine so etwas macht man nur wenn
man den Vater Zivilisation eindeutig und
endgültig verlassen hat und mit genau
dieser Barbara sind die Ukraine direkt
und tagtäglich konfrontiert trotzdem
besagen Umfragen dass die große Mehrheit
von ihnen bis zum Ende kämpfen will sie
wollen die Russen aus ihrem Land
vertreiben koste es was es wollen und
sie wollen erreichen das von ihrem
mörderischen Nachbarn nie wieder eine
Gefahr für Sie oder irgendein anderes
Land ausgegeben kann du glaubst mir
nicht denkst du ich übertreibe dann sie
dich doch mal um mehr als 80% der
Ukraine erleben territoriale
Zugeständnisse ab selbst auf die Gefahr
dass sich der Krieg in die Länge zieht
aber wie ist es überhaupt möglich dass
sie obwohl alles gegen sie sprachen
nicht beschlossen haben aufzugeben als
die Invasion begann wie haben Sie es
geschafft die ganze Zeit eisern
durchzuhalten warum in aller Welt wollen
die Ukraine weiterkämpfen wieso sind
dort so viele junge Menschen bereit bis
zum Äußersten zu gehen
[Musik]
der ukrainische Widerstand hat mehrere
Zutaten die schon lange köcheln und
weißt du was um die erste von ihnen zu
verstehen müssen wir bis zum Anfang des
20 Jahrhunderts zurückgeben genauer
gesagt in den Oktober 2017 als die
Revolution im Russischen Reich ausbrach
und damit die Hölle auf Erden auch in
der Ukraine die nachdem sie sich als
unabhängige Republik vom Russischen
Reich losgerissen hatte einen
Bürgerkrieg zwischen zwei Seiten erlebte
der ukrainischen Volksrepublik
unterstützt von Deutschland und
Österreich Ungarn auf der einen Seite
und der ukrainischen sozialistischen
Sowjet Republik unterstützt von den
Bolschewiki auf der anderen Seite am
Ende setzten sich die letzteren durch
und 1922 schloss sich die Ukraine mit
Russland Weißrussland und den
südkorkasus zur UdSSR der Union der
Sozialistischen Sowjet Republiken
zusammen eine Vereinigung die sich schon
nach kurzer Zeit als absolute
Katastrophe erwiesen
[Musik]
in den 1930er Jahren waren die Vorteile
der Integration in die Sowjetunion
praktisch verschwunden Stalis
Agrarpolitik die auf Land Kontaktierung
und Kollektivierung basierte traf das
Land das als Kornkammer der UdSSR
bekannt war wie kein anderes Bauern die
versuchten ihr Land zu behalten wurden
unterdrückt in Konzentrationslager
deportiert und sogar hingerichtet
ihre Ernten wurden vom Militär gewaltsam
konfisziert und in die Städte nach
Russland gebracht von den Reichen
Erträgen blieb in der Ukraine kaum noch
ein Korn übrig das Ergebnis zwischen
dreieinhalb und acht Millionen Ukraine
starben einen grausamen Hungertod im
besten Fall waren dies 10% der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung die aufgrund
von Entscheidungen aus Moskau verhunger
sind das war die Zeit die später als
Holo domore bekannt geworden ist ein
Völkermord durch gezieltes aushungern
der leider oft verschwiegen oder
vergessen wird aber selbst diese Hölle
war nur der Anfang in den Jahren des
talinismus förderte der oberste verwirrt
aktiv die russinifizierung der Ukraine
das bedeutet dass der Gebrauch der
ukrainische Sprache und jeder andere
Aspekt der lokalen Kultur eingeschränkt
und sogar unterdrückt wurde das Maß der
Unterdrückung haben immer weiter zu nach
sali ist tot bekam die Ukraine zwar eine
kurze attenpause während nikitakustchas
Zeit an der Spitze des roten Reiches
aber dann kehrte Moskau für gleichen
Strategie zurück wenn auch nicht mehr so
brutal und offensichtlich wie
unterliegen
zu allem Überfluss kam es nach Jahren
der Armut und Schwerfälligkeit 1986 zur
Tschernobyl-Katastrophe die von der
sowjetischen Führung in Moskau wieder
einmal furchtbar schlecht gemanagt wurde
sie wurde zum Symbol des gesamtversagen
des Sowjetsystems du siehst also
jahrzehntelang haben Moskau und damit
Russland und die Russen nicht gerade
viele Freundschaftspunkte gesammelt um
die Herzen der Ukraine zu gewinnen und
vielleicht war das der Grund warum diese
nach der Perestroika und dem
Zusammenbruch der UdSSR im Oktober 91
ganz klare Ziele hat sie wollten wieder
ein unabhängiges Land werden das eine
Geschichte selbst leitet die Ukraine
haben damals in einem Referendum
abgestimmt und die Unabhängigkeit mit
überwältigender Mehrheit gewonnen
schaust dir an wie du sehen kannst hat
die Unabhängigkeitsbewegung in allen
Regionen des Landes gewonnen sie hat mit
überwältigender mehr als selbst im Don
Bass und auch auf der Creme und in
silver Folge gesetzt aber wir wollen
nicht voreilig sein wenn die
Unabhängigkeit hat die Tentakel und die
Einflussnahme moskaust nicht verkürzt
ganz im Gegenteil
[Musik]
der Zug nach Brüssel ist abgefahren
in fast allen Posts sowjetischen Ländern
verlief die Abkehr vom Kommunismus
furchtbar schwierig alle
gesellschaftlichen Strukturen waren auf
grausame Weise verwahrlost und verdorben
und mussten von Grund auf neu erfunden
und errichtet werden das war natürlich
auch in der Ukraine nicht anders der
öffentliche Sektor war eine riesiges
Chaos der gigantische staatsoperate und
die erdrückende Abhängigkeit von Moskau
waren allgegenwärtig und die Länder
mussten inmitten einer brutalen
Wirtschaftskrise von Grund auf neu
aufgebaut werden um die eine Vorstellung
zu geben zwischen 1991 und 98 ist die
Wirtschaft der Ukraine um mehr als 60%
eingebrochen tatsächlich gab es erst zu
Beginn des neuen Jahrtausend das erste
Anzeichen einer Erholung aber dann ein
paar Jahre später kam die große
Finanzkrise und alles gegen wieder den
Bach runter es war eine Katastrophe das
Land schien dazu verdammt zu sein eine
nie wieder aus diesen Abgrund entkommen
zu können doch nach der großen Krise von
2008 änderte sich etwas plötzlich ergab
sich die Möglichkeit ein
Assoziierungsabkommen mit der
Europäischen Union zu unterzeichnen
darüber hinaus wurden große
Erdgasvorkommen in der Nähe der Krim und
im Don Bass gefunden mit ihnen hätte die
Ukraine zu einem wichtigen
Energieversorger Europas und damit
Konkurrenten Russlands werden können und
natürlich verdammt reich aber weißt du
was das auch bedeutet hätte der Zugang
zum gemeinsamen europäischen Markt hätte
alles verändern können plötzlich konnten
alle möglichen ukrainischen Produkte in
den Westen fließen als gäbe es kein
Morgen außerdem könnten europäische
Investitionen und mit ihren westliches
Know-how helfen das Land zu
modernisieren mit steigenden Wohlstand
und der Bildung einer stabilen
Mittelschicht hätte man auch die
Korruption in den Griff kriegen können
tja aber leider müssen wir an dieser
Stelle unsere Euphorie zügeln denn es
gab ein Problem und nicht nur ein
kleines ich glaube du kannst erraten
worum es sich handelt genau die
moskowita die das größte Land der Erde
beherrschen
zunächst liefen die Verhandlungen mit
der Europäischen Union unter Volldampf
an doch gerade als sie kurz vor einem
erfolgreichen Abschluss zu stehen
Schienen gerieten sie plötzlich völlig
aus den Fugen Präsident
viktorianukowitsch der versprochen hatte
das Abkommen voranzutreiben hat den
Prozess eingefroren und ist überrascht
nicht das Russland hinter diesen Schritt
stand 21 November 2013 die Ukraine lässt
den Plan sich den besten zu öffnen
fallen und wendet sich dem Osten zu
Januar welches terminminister gab den
dramatischen Befehl den Prozess im
Interesse der nationalen Sicherheit
auszusetzen und den aktiven Dialog mit
Moskau wieder aufzunehmen man muss sich
das mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen im
Interesse der nationalen Sicherheit klar
das sieht man ja heute wie gut das für
die nationale Sicherheit der Ukraine war
in Wahrheit ging es natürlich um etwas
ganz anderes die Interessen von jemand
ganz andere die Vorstellung dass die
ehemaligen mit dem besten flirten reich
werden und sich vielleicht
demokratisieren war etwas das Putin
nicht wahrhaben wollte die Ukraine
hätten zu einem Vorbild auch für die
Russen werden können und das wäre das
Todesurteil für seine Macht gewesen die
Entwicklung in der Ukraine gefiel ihm
deswegen so wenig wie Dracula Knoblauch
zum Frühstück
alle Ukraine seiner Macht unterwerfen
und nur allein seiner Macht und falls
Sie das nicht tun würden müsste er die
Ukraine klein und Arm halten ständig
Unruhe und Instabilität in dem
landstiften das große Problem meine
lieben Freunde war nur dass der
russische Präsident 2013 genauso wie
2022 nicht richtig eingeschätzt hat wie
sich die Ukraine fühlen werden wenn sie
herumgeschubst werden tja und dann
geschah das große Unglück Hörzu
mehr gegen Hoffnung
[Musik]
am 22 November 2013 heißt das Einfrieren
das Abkommen das mit der Europäischen
Union bekannt gegeben wurde ganz wichtig
die Stimmung auf dem Platz der
Unabhängigkeit auch bekannt als Maidan
anzuheizen politische Parteien Social
Media Plattformen Aktivisten plötzlich
wurde dieser Platz zum Epizentrum eines
gigantischen Anti regierungsproteste ist
mit aber Tausenden von Menschen die
gesamte Opposition gegen jannikowitsch
und gegen seine Ernährung an Moskau war
hier vertreten
es war genau derselbe Ort an dem 2004
die Orange Revolution gegen den
Wahlbetrug stattgefunden hatte umiane
kovic selbst zum Präsidenten zu machen
zum Nachteil seines pro europäischen
Gegners victoriouschenko der übrigens im
Wahlkampf desselben Jahres Opfer eines
giftanschlags wurde den er schwer
entstellt überlegt wer ihn damals
vergiftet hat das konnte bis heute nicht
ermittelt werden aber du kannst dir
denken wer der Hauptverdächtige dabei
ist in diesem Fall wie in so vielen
anderen führen alle Wege nach Moskau
[Musik]
wir haben über die vergiftungspolitik
des Krems ein eigenes Video gedreht dass
ich dir natürlich verlinke
die Situation eskalierte schnell im
Januar 2014 versuchte die Regierung die
Demonstranten mit harten Repressionen
und Gewalt von Platz zu vertreiben es
gab Dutzende von Toten und Verletzten
die Demonstranten organisierten sich und
gründeten Verteidigungseinheiten die
Ukraine stand am Rande eines
Bürgerkriegs doch glücklicherweise
endete alles mit dem Rücktritt und der
Flucht des Präsidenten niano Kovac er
ging zu seinen Freunden nach Russland
dies war eine sehr schwere Niederlage
für Moskau aber Moment mal war wirklich
alles vorbei nein natürlich nicht
Vladimir Putin wollte nicht tatenlos
zusehen ihr erinnert euch sicher an
Nachrichten wie diese erste märz 2014
russische Invasion auf der krimisch wird
Ängste vor einem ukrainekonflikt 7 märz
2014 einundzwanzig mal haben
Journalisten bestätigt dass es sich bei
den maskierten Truppen auf der Krim um
Russen handelt die russische Operation
endete mit zwei vernichtende Niederlagen
für die ukrainischen Streitkräfte in der
Tat Putin hat ein Machtwort gesprochen
und beschlossen einen Gegenangriff zu
starten das tat er indem er zunächst in
die Ukraine einmarschiert und sieht dann
annektierte gleichzeitig heizt er mit
verdeckt operierenden
infiltrationsgruppen ein Bürgerkrieg im
Donbass an der traditionell am stärksten
industrialisierten Region der Ukraine zu
dieser Zeit konnte die Ukraine praktisch
nichts dagegen unternehmen heißt der
Krieg auf der Krim im Februar 2014
begann konnten nur etwa 50.000 Soldaten
eingesetzt werden von denen aber nur
etwa 6000 kampfbereit waren die
russische Operation endete mit zwei
vernichtende Niederlagen für die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte das Ergebnis
der Verlust der Grimm und die Ausrufung
von zwei neuen Republiken die heute
ebenfalls von Russland Adjektiv sind der
Volksrepublik Deutschland
zwei marionettenstaaten die absolut von
Moskau abhängig sind und weißt du was
auch diese Operation führte in einem
wahres Desaster
[Musik]
in den neuen Republiken wurden alle
demokratischen Institutionen zerstört
ein ultra-nationalistisches
ultrakonservatives und ultra
militäristisches Staats- und
Gesellschaftsmodell wurde brutal von den
Russen durchgesetzt Andersdenkende
wurden verhaftet gefoltert ermordet eine
Klima der Angst und Totalität geschaffen
dass jenes in Russland noch weit
übertrifft viele wenn ich sogar die
meisten großen Unternehmen und
Produktionsanlagen die Bergwerke und
Stahlwerke wurden enteignet oder Moskau
freundlichen Oligarchen zur Verfügung
gestellt ein Prozess ganz ähnlich der
Arisierung jüdischen Eigentums durch die
Nazis die Wirtschaftstätigkeit brach
zusammen und Arbeitsplätze verschwanden
es wird geschätzt dass etwa die Hälfte
also 50% der gesamten Bevölkerung ihre
Koffer packte und nach Russland ist
übrigens Europa und vor allem in die
übrigen Ukraine ging in erster Linie in
den nahegelegenen Regionen wie du dir
vorstellen kannst löst Moskau und der
Gedanke an eine russische Herrschaft bei
diesen Menschen auch nicht gerade
positive Gefühle aus Putin hat sie aus
ihrer Heimat vertrieben angeblich um sie
zu beschützen schau dir an was ein
Schriftsteller aus der Region Ende 2021
sagte sie haben es geschafft in den
besetzten Gebieten ein sowjetisches
System wieder aufzubauen und zwar nicht
das sowjetische System der 1960er oder
70er Jahre sondern das sowjetische
System der 1930er und 40er Jahre mit
Kerkern mit Folterkammern ins Systeme
indem er Leben ruiniert werden wenn man
es wagt etwas Negatives über diese
Republiken und ihre Behörden zu
schreiben oder zu sagen der russisch
besetzt wurde für die Ukraine zum
perfekten Schaufenster dafür was ihnen
allen blühen würde wenn sie nicht
schnell genug in die pushen kommen um
sich gegen Putins perverse Beschützer
Gelüste verteidigungsfähig zu machen und
an dieser Stelle muss ich noch etwas
anderes klarstellen da es von vielen
Putin Sympathisanten leider immer noch
gebetsmühlenartig wiederholt wird die
Ukraine hat in Don was zwischen 2014 und
2021 nicht 14.000 Russen ermordet das
ist ein übler aber umso hartnäckiger
Mythos den die Camel Propaganda
erschaffen hat um damit sowohl die
gehirner der Russen als auch ihre fünf
Kolonnen im Ausland zu waschen die
Wahrheit ist nämlich die folgende die
meisten Todesopfer in diesen Konflikt
waren ganz einfach Soldaten und auf
russischer Seite waren es eben
Invasionstruppen auch wenn diese ohne
offizielles russisches Abzeichen
operierten UN-Angaben zufolge starben
auf beiden Seiten der Frontlinie 3.106
Zivilisten die meisten davon jedoch in
den Anfangsjahren das Konfliktes in den
letzten Jahren waren kaum noch zivile
Opfer zu beklagen 2020 waren es 26 und
2021 dann 25 und in diesen beiden Jahren
handelt es sich meist um Minenopfer das
heißt von einem
bomberisten durch die Ukraine konnte da
keine Rede sein übrigens hat dies alles
Wagner Boss in selbst am
23.06.2023 in seiner Tacheles Rede
bestätigt der Einfahrt Russland in die
Ukraine hatte keinerlei berechtigte
Grundlage es war ein purer Akt der
Aggression von Schutz keine Spur und auf
jeden Fall sind die Opferzahlen von vor
2022 auch kein Vergleich zu den
gewaltigen Opferzahlen die die Russen
mit ihren Invasionen zu verantworten
haben denn diese gehen wahrlich in die
Zehntausende es war also vor allem das
Verhalten der Russen selbst ihr Terror
artiger Interventionismus und gieriger
Expansionismus was die Ukraine dazu
zwingen ihre Streitkräfte wieder
aufzubauen mit anderen Worten wegen
Russland musste das ernste Land in
Europa seit Anfang 2014 seine
Militärausgaben mehr als verdoppeln
natürlich hat die Zeit ihnen recht
gegeben wir alle wissen von den brutalen
Massakern den Vergewaltigung und den
Entführungen der Entführung tausender
von Kindern den filtrations- und
Konzentrationslagern und unzähligen
weiteren Verbrechen die die großen seit
dem 24 Februar 2022 an den Ukrainern
begangen haben all die Militärausgaben
zur Verteidigung der Ukraine waren also
dringend notwendig damit nicht die
gesamte Bevölkerung das erleiden muss
was diejenigen die aus dem besetzten
Gebieten nicht schnell genug fliehen
konnten erleiden mussten und noch immer
müssen wie gesagt all das wenn auch
nicht in jedem genozidalen Ausmaß konnte
man damals schon anhand der Beispiele in
Don jetzt und Johannes erahnen niemand
kann behaupten von nichts gewusst zu
haben tja auch das erinnert einen an
andere dunkle Zeiten aber die gute
Nachricht für keine damals war dass
manche durchaus bewusst war was kommen
würde und somit auch internationale
Hilfe haben schau es dir an 24 Februar
2015 britische Militärausbildung in der
Ukraine symbolischer Schritt der den
Zorn Russland provoziert 24 gestern
november 2015 US-Truppen beginnen mit
der Ausbildung ukrainischer regulärer
Streitkräfte und so bereiteten sich die
Ukraine und insbesondere die Ukrainer
selbst nach und nach auf einen Krieg vor
bis zu 24 Februar 2022 als Putin
schließlich seinen Feuersturm
entfesselte doch wie wir alle wissen ist
seither viel Zeit vergangen und der
Krieg geht nicht nur weiter sondern es
sind die Ukrainer selbst die die
Initiative ergreifen und jetzt wissen
wir auch warum sie sich so verbissen
wären
würden sie es nicht tun würden sie unter
russischer Herrschaft im besten Fall
ihre Freiheit verlieren und im
schlimmsten ihr Leben aber trotzdem was
erklärt eigentlich ihre enorme Ausdauer
wieso sind sie aus Verzweiflung nicht
schon längst zusammengebrochen nun lass
uns dazu doch mal eine kleine
gedankenübung machen stellen wir uns für
einen Moment vor wir gehen zurück zum 25
Februar 2022 wir sind Ukraine und wir
sind jung die russische Invasion hat
gerade begonnen Raketen und Bomben
fallen auf die Ukraine während versuchen
die wichtigsten Städte des Landes zu
erreichen darunter auch die Hauptstadt
wir sind in einer unabhängigen korrupten
aber trotzdem demokratischen Ukraine
geboren in der die Tentakeln moskauz
trotzdem überall hinreichen deine
Großeltern haben die vom Holunder und
den Verwandten erzählt die sie wegen
Moskau verloren haben sie haben dir auch
erzählt wie die Sowjetunion versucht hat
die Ukraine zu russifizieren deine
Eltern und Großeltern haben die erzählt
wie schwierig ihr Leben war und
Unterdrückung und wahrscheinlich auch
von der politischen Polizei den
gefürchteten KGB du hast über die
Katastrophe von Tschernobyl gelesen oder
Staatsversagen dass sie verursacht hat
du hast den durch moskauz miterlebt ein
Land vom Westen abzuschneiden und von
der anschließenden euromeidan Revolution
du hast das Grauen des Krieges von 2014
miterlebt und kennst vielleicht Menschen
die in diesen Krieg gestorben sind die
Opfer waren oder mobilisiert wurden
trotz alldem hast du in den letzten
Jahren davon geträumt dass die Ukraine
sich modernisiert und sich den
wohlhabenderen Ländern Europas
anschließt stattdessen erlebst du jetzt
aber wieder einmal wie die russische
Regierung dein Land mit bombenraketen
Panzern und Soldaten zerstört und
vernichtet wie der Herrscher im Kreml
dich unter Jochen möchte die Frage die
sich viele Ukraine daher stellten und
noch immer Stellen lautet also wieso
haben wir alle ich schon viel früher
vereint den Kampf aufgenommen um uns vom
russenjoch endgültig zu befreien
[Musik]
und auf diese Weise ist die erdrückende
Mehrheit Ukrainer zu einem ganz klaren
Schluss gekommen entweder sie besiegen
Russland ein für alle Mal und machen es
langfristig unschädlich oder sie werden
nie in der Lage sein ein normales
wohlhabendes und friedliches Land zu
haben Russland ist zu ihrem schlimmsten
Albtraum geworden und das niederringen
der moskvita zu ihrer wichtigsten
Mission denn andererseits könnte die
Ukraine wenn Sie es schaffen Russland zu
besiegen innerhalb weniger Jahre der
Europäischen Union in der nato- und
damit versuchen die beeindruckenden
Entwicklung von Ländern die Polen und
den baltischen Republiken nachzuahmen
und genau das ist die Erklärung für die
Nachricht die wir vorhin gesehen haben
mehr als 80 % der Ukraine erleben
territoriale Zugeständnisse ab selbst
auf die Gefahr hin dass sich der Krieg
in die Länge zieht wie du aus der Bibel
sind diese Umfrage des Tiere
international Instituts für
gesellschaftsforschung sehen kannst sind
die Ukraine mehrheitlich bereits weiter
zu kämpfen um ihr Territorium zurück zu
gewinnen sie wissen ganz genau dass sie
nie Ruhe haben werden wenn sie es nicht
schaffen die russische Armee zu
zerschlagen dass sie sonst dazu verdammt
werden auf immer und ewig in einem
ähnlichen Zustand wie Israel zu leben
mit ewigen Terror nur eben mit ewigen
Terror der nicht von ein paar Armen
entwurzelten schlecht organisierten
Arabern kommt sondern von einem 100
Millionen Volk wie du siehst sind sie
sozusagen mit einer Alles oder Nichts
Situationen konfrontiert und deswegen
haben sie sich Liebe für alles
entschieden und die Frage die bleibt ist
natürlich ob sie erfolgreich sein werden
ob sie Russland tatsächlich besiegen
können und deswegen jetzt noch wie
eingangs versprochen ein paar Worte zu
den viel zitierten expertenanalysen die
besagen dass die ukrainische gegen
Offensive gescheitert wäre
oberste Reise nach erste Phase der
ukrainischen Offensive ist aus meiner
Sicht gescheitert hierzu ist vor allem
anzumerken dass diese Interpretation in
erster Linie auf einem falschen
Verständnis der verschiedenen
offensivphasen beruht natürlich muss die
Ukraine in ihrer Situation eine
vollkommene nicht da gewesene Strategie
entwickeln eben damit andere nicht
verstehen was sie tun und vorhat nur so
können gewisse Überraschungseffekte
gewahrt bleiben dadurch sind natürlich
nicht nur die russischen Gegner verwirrt
sondern auch die Militärs anderer z.B
neutraler Staaten die sind ja meist auch
nicht in die Information Loop der NATO
und damit der Ukraine eingebunden wie
der Open Source intelligence eine List
Thomas Teil einer nämlich korrekt
bemerkt wird ist wohl fünf offensiv
Phasen geben und wir befinden uns gerade
mitten ja genau der ersten in dieser
geht es um die Ermüdung und zermürung
des Gegner sowie die Unterbrechung und
Ausbildung seiner logistischen
Versorgungslinien und die Unterbindung
seiner Bewegungsfähigkeiten doch hierzu
muss er aus der Reserve gelockt werden
um sein schweres Gerät und die
entsprechenden Punkte dann durch
Fernwaffen auszuschalten normalerweise
wird dies durch Luftschläge erzielt dies
ist ja die gängige beginnt der USA und
der NATO da die Ukraine aber leider
nicht über diese Möglichkeit verfügt
muss sie viel kreativer vorgehen
zum Vergleich während des Golfkriegs von
1991 der Operation desertstorm brauchten
die mir als 1700 Kampfflugzeuge der
US-geführten Koalitionstruppen über
einen Monat und mehr als 100.000
Einsätze und knapp 300 marschflowkörper
und die irakischen Streitkräfte so weit
zu vermürden dass die bodenkampagne
eingeleitet werden konnte man als
Luftwaffe muss die Ukraine aber diese
Lücke im offensiv Raum durch präzisions
Artillerie marschflowkörper und Drohnen
überbrücken erst wenn sie damit die
entsprechenden analogen Ziele erreicht
hat lohnt es sich mit der
hauptstadtmacht am Boden vorzurücken
alle bisherigen Vorschüsse der mobilen
Bodentruppen hatten also nur den Zweck
den Gegner quasi aufzusuchen um ihn in
Bewegung zu versetzen aufzuklären eine
Reichweite zu bringen und seine
Versorgungslinien auszudrücken aber was
meine ich damit eigentlich konkret nun
lasst es mich erklären die gesamte
echtzeitaufklärung der Ukraine muss mit
Drohnen erfolgen und teilweise aber er
begrenzt durch Satelliten die Drohnen
müssen wenn sie Ziele ausgemacht haben
die Position dann an die
geschützleitstelle weitergeben aber dies
erfordert eben einen viel größeren
Zeitaufwand mehr Kommunikation und viel
vorsichtigeres Vorgehen als wenn man
Lufthoheit über fand ich im Gebiet
besäße und eine riesige jagebombe Flotte
Ziele direkt ausmachen und sofort
bombardieren könnte darüber hinaus ist
es für die Ukraine deswegen auch viel
schwieriger bewegliche Ziele zu treffen
und diese müssen sich darüber hinaus
viel näher an der Frontlinie befinden
zum Vergleich ein moderner Kampfjet kann
innerhalb einer Mission Dutzende von
Zielen vernichten die Hunderte von
Kilometern hinter der Front liegen die
Artillerie System der Ukraine reichen
maximal 84 km weit die stormkörper haben
zwar eine Reichweite von über 500 km
aber die Ukraine muss sie für ihre
strategischen Ziele aufheben mit ihnen
einzelne Panzer auszuschalten wäre
kontraproduktiv die Russen wissen das
alles natürlich und versuchen daher ihre
panzerhaufen und so weiter möglichst
außer Atelier Reichweite zu halten das
Problem die Streitkräfte der Ukraine
können nur dann Phase 2 starten wenn Sie
dieses russische schwere Gerät zerstört
haben wenn sie ihre Munition und
Treibstoff der Brust vernichtet und die
Versorgungslinien ausgedünnt haben und
das alles geht eben nur indem sie diese
in die Reichweite ihre Artillerie locken
die Ukraine tut momentan eben genau
genau das indem sie die russischen
Linien mit vier ihrer zehn Brigaden
Angreifer die für diese Phase
vorbereitet wurden deswegen müssen im
Vergleich zu anderen offensivarten in
dieser Phase den notwendigen Ziele viel
langsamer erreicht werden das alles war
aber gut bekannt und eingeplant daher
kann von einem Misserfolg keine Rede
sein die russische Streitkräfte stecken
dadurch nämlich in einem Dilemma wieso
nun erinnert ihr euch wie ich gesagt
habe dass an Phase 1 zur Zeit nur vier
von zehn dafür vorgesehenen ukrainischen
Brigaden beteiligt sind das heißt es
könnten noch locker weitere sechs
Brigaden zur Erfüllung der ziel dieser
Phase eingesetzt werden und diese sechs
Brigaden sind sozusagen der ukrainische
Joker denn wenn die Russen ja schweres
Gerät weit hinter der Frontlinie packen
müssen um nicht unter das aktuelle
Ukraine zu geraten riskieren Sie das
Ausführen bestimmter Abschnitt der Front
und dort könnten die sechs Brigaden dann
konzentrierte unerwartet einen Freund
Durchbruch also noch vor Phase 2
einleiten das heißt die russischen
Truppen müssen immer mehr von ihrem
schweren Gerät und ihre Logistik weiter
an die frontlinge bringen und dadurch
riskieren es im Artillerie Feuer zu
verlieren oder aber sie lassen ihr
schweres Gerät und ihre Logistik
ausreichweite und ermöglichen der
Ukraine dann eben den Durchbruch aber
ihr merkt schon in dieser ersten Phase
geht es nicht um Geländegewinne das
alles ist ein langsamer bildlich
ausgedrückt tröpfchenweise Prozess ein
ständiges Hin und Her provozieren
zuschlagen sich zurückziehen und
wiederholen so lange bis die russischen
Kräfte ausgelaugt sind das Problem ist
natürlich das im Gegensatz zum
Lufthoheit auch die Ukraine bei diesem
provokationsaktionen Bodentruppen und
Fahrzeuge verliert und die Bilder dieser
ukrainischen Verluste die die russischen
militärblogger in alle Welt Posten
führen dann so Aussagen manche Analysten
die Offensive sei gescheitert die erste
Phase der ukrainischen Offensive ist aus
meiner Sicht gescheitert die Armee hat
versucht wie aus einem Lehrbuch der
US-Armee massiert vorzustoßen dann aber
gemerkt dass die Russen zu gut
vorbereitet sind um einen Durchbruch zu
erzielen die aktuelle Lage ist wie bei
einem American Footballspiel beide
Seiten stehen in einer Ausgangsposition
und dann rennen die Spieler bei der
Teams aufeinander zu und entweder es
gelingt ein Durchbruch oder man ist
Schulter an Schulter eingehängt und
versucht stärker zu sein als der andere
ja so ist es aber eben nicht
zu einer solchen Einschätzung können wir
anhand der folgenden Informationen nicht
kommen zum einen besteht wie gesagt eben
gerade die US-Strategie darin den Gegner
vor jeder Bodenoffensive erstmal aus der
Luft zu zermürgen bevor es irgendwelche
massierten Vorstöße gibt darüber hinaus
stellt sich die Frage woher diese
Information über massierte Vorstöße
überhaupt kommt und zum anderen müsste
man für eine qualifizierte Analyse auch
wissen was das Ziel jeder einzelne
Operation war ob die es erreicht wurde
wie das verlustverhältnis war ob die
Verluste reparabel oder ersetzbar sind
und so weiter und so fort ich bin
jedesmal ziemlich frustriert wenn in
Analysen die von Mainstream Medien
verbreitet werden all diese Aspekte
fehlen klar wenn irgendjemand sowas auf
YouTube oder Twitter behauptet handelt
es sich um eine offene Diskussion den
Austausch von Meinungen Media alle
Berichterstattung sollte jedoch
fundierte und seriöser sein davon dass
die ukrainische gegen Offensive
gescheiter zeigt kann also keine Fall
die Rede sein ich denke dass jeder der
dies behauptet einfach nicht verstanden
hat wie das Vorgehen der Ukraine
grundlegend funktioniert ansonsten gilt
noch immer was wir in unserem
initialvideo zu gegen Offensive gesagt
haben falls ihr es nicht gesehen habt
werde ich es euch natürlich verlinken
und ihr könnt es euch im Anschluss
ansehen fakt ist zum Zeitpunkt der
Aufnahme dieses Videos befinden sich
mehr als 9/10 der ukrainischen Offensive
Truppen noch immer nicht im Front
Einsatz die ukrainische Armee Führung
wird sie erst dann einsetzen wenn Sie
sicher genug ist dass die Lage reif ist
für die nächste Phase das wird der Fall
sein wenn die russische Artillerie
Luftverteidigung und Logistik so stark
ausgedünnt sind dass die eigenen
Verluste gering sein werden ganz genau
so wie es auch immer bei den
amerikanischen offensiv Kampagnen der
Fall war nur dass die USA dies eben mit
Hilfe ihrer Überlegenheit in der Luft
erreichen konnten und im Falle der
Ukraine ist es sogar noch wichtiger dass
das verlustverhältnis gesund bleibt die
Ukraine muss bei jedem Einsatz viel
weniger Verluste haben als die Russen
nur dann kann sie gewinnen zum Glück
sieht ist danach aus dass sie dieses
Ziel erreichen kann trotzdem schade dass
der Westen so lange mit den F16 gezögert
hat dann ging es noch schneller und noch
mit viel weniger Verlusten und auch die
Experten hätten es dann viel einfacher
ihr Vorgehen zu interpretieren aber da
die nicht so ist werden wir dich
natürlich weiterhin auf dem laufenden
halten vergisst also bitte nicht das Abo
mit Glöckchen um jedes unserer mit
echten Fakten vollgestopften Videos
rechtzeitig genießen zu können und bis
dahin bis erstmal wieder du an der Reihe
wenn du Ukrainer wärst wie hättest du
auf die russische Invasion reagiert
würdest du dein Heimatland ebenso
hartnäckig verteidigen wie sie oder
würdest du lieber mit den Invasoren
kollaborieren um deine eigene Haut zu
retten und wie stellst du die
ukrainische gegen Offensive ein was
hältst du von all den Militärexperten
und ihren Urteilen wie oft liegen sie
richtig und wie oft falsch findest du es
gut dass die Mainstream in so viel Raum
und Reichweite bieten wie immer sind auf
eure Diskussion von diesem Thema schon
mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass euch
dieses Video gefallen hat und die
vielleicht auch was dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gib uns bitte ein Like heißt
mit euren Freunden und diskutiert ist
mit ihnen ausgegeben natürlich wollen
wir uns auch jederzeit über eine Spende
von euch weiterzuführen den Link dazu
findet ihr in der Beschreibung unter dem
Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]